so there is this recording of the soccer
match which is
quite interesting because the camera
of the match is ai controlled which just
means that it's
programmed to track the ball now it
tracks the ball
by visual features and what's funny
about this particular one is that
the ai switches constantly between the
ball
and the bald head of one of the referees
which if you look at it looks exactly
alike especially in low resolution at
which i guess the camera
would operate on yeah if you haven't
seen it go look at it it's quite funny
but it highlights a more interesting
point technology fails
now this particular system it's it's
probably not
very much ai it's not very smart i can
guess
that it's very standard kind of feature
extractor maybe something like a huff
transform
with a few sifter surf features here and
there to
look at the color things and
kind of low level information to to
track the ball
is usually enough and it's probably more
robust than deep learning
uh let's be honest here but while this
instance is funny
uh a lot of times when these systems
fail they
have bad or even catastrophic
consequences let's say
a self-driving car mixes up a
head of a child consequences can be
quite
grave so i would like to put this to the
sort of people who advocate for having
things like broader impact statements in
papers and saying that the entire ai
research process should be
filled with considerations of ethics to
the
end application we all agree that these
things can fail but
let's take this particular instance
right here if this system is trained at
all
it's probably not trained on too many
bald heads
and therefore simply mixes up the ball
in the bald head because it looks
almost the same interestingly enough
this is one of the
situations where the system
disproportion
often fails for white men but let's
leave that out of the picture for now
where in this process exactly should
someone step in and say
wait this is uh ethically concerning
should the inventor of the huff
transform i don't know who that was
maybe
alfred huff pool half say ha
you know if if my system detects circles
and images
then obviously the negative consequences
could be that it mixes up
a head with a ball interestingly enough
the wikipedia page of the circle huff
transform
says that it can be used to detect
people's heads uh i just thought that
was funny where in the process
except at the end when someone actually
takes the technology
and puts it into a camera that person
should consider the failure modes
knowing what the technology is about
to go to the inventor of a circle
detector
and expect from them to predict kind of
these negative outcomes
is ludicrous i'm sorry try to write the
broader impact statement for the huff
transform
doubt you would have come up with this
failure mode or anything similar to it
if it hadn't actually happened and you
shouldn't like
circle detectors are useful
and they sometimes fail and when they
fail
we'll deal with it after all even with
the best broader impact statement this
wouldn't have been prevented that was
just my two cents go check it out
have fun bye-bye
[Music]
you